yeah we'll wait for uh the committee
members before we open up I'm going to
open up the uh executive session for one
o'clock
all right so the time being 1 o'clock uh
welcome to uh Public Works and highways
we have an executive session scheduled
to begin now I'm going to go into recess
for no more than 10 minutes and we will
resume at that time uh Republicans and
Democrats are going to caucus thank you
okay and what I'll do with that we'll
meet over by the window next to
representative Greg and as I said so
we'll
thank
e
thank you uh um all one one more time
here uh welcome you back uh from Recess
Public Works and highways executive
session uh we are going to take up our
five bills that are before the committee
today um and that'll be I believe the
end of our work that we have before us
um so I would I would like to I'm going
to take uh a little bit out of order I'm
going to save House Bill 110 for the
last uh and we're going to start with on
our list here House Bill
199 uh Mr chairman yes I make the motion
of itl on House Bill
199 um motion made by cluder
to um itl House Bill 199 seconded by
Mills uh further discussion on House
Bill
199 Mr chair yes I have talked the prime
sponsor and she is okay with it Ling
this bill uh I have some major concerns
the way it's written and I know there's
another bill that will'll be I we will
consider next year as a full house and
probably this committee so we can
further debate this issue next year but
I I I don't I'm not do not think this
bill is ready to pass and in any case
the prime sponsor is more comfortable
with itl thank not the bill that we're
yes CH F I'm not sure
your is it 199 the rail appropriation is
the one before us no I'm
sorry you're right it is okay yeah right
so
I I just think for the record that that
that I support itl because this confus
it with 361 I apologize no problem 199
okay I'll go back this is something
we've done in the past uh our committee
has always done this we put it in just
as a placeholder in case for some Reas
reason this money for the Carrol
statford and Coos County Freight rail
Improvement projects do not make it in
the capital budget and I have done this
for years with often either represent
mcon or represent Graham and usually in
the end we haven't needed it because it
ends up in the capital budget so I this
bill is no longer necessary so I would
ask that we uh uh approve the itl motion
because we don't longer need this Bill
thank you motion so made by cler
seconded by Mills correct thank you um
if you're in favor of the motion itl
relative the appropriation of the Carrol
straford Coos County Freight Line
Improvement projects uh you'll signify
by saying I when I you want a roll call
roll call okay any further discussion
before the the roll
[Music]
call and I apologize Mr chair for
confusing my bills
if that's the worst thing that happens
to us today Mr Vice chair we'll be fine
please M clerk call the
RO representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fidi yes representative
Newton oh I'm sorry representative
kazinski yes
representative Bowden yes representative
Boyd Boyd votes I representative Melvin
yes representative bogert yes
representative Connor
is representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
representative Eaton yes representative
Peterson
yes our representative guest Greg
yes represent representative jurus yes
chairman mccon I Mr chair the vote is
180 EA thank
you we will now move on excuse me Mr
should we put this on consent I I don't
object myself but there's no funds I uh
any objection to putting this on consent
calendar seeing none we'll put it on
consent thank you for
that next bill we will uh take up is um
we've already started the conversation
House Bill
361 uh relative peace Development
Authority board of
directors and food did you have a yes I
again I would move itl on House Bill 361
and basically this is the speech I just
gave on the first bill I as I said I got
confused I have a problem with the way
the bill is written and in any case next
term we are going to consider a similar
Bill uh as I said so I think uh it's a
bill which is a little bit better and
I'm keeping an open mind on but in any
case I talk to the prime sponsor and she
is comfortable with it Ling House Bill
361 any further discussion we need a
second a second would
be I second that thank you R Mills
motion's been made and seconded to uh
itl House Bill
361 any further
discussion seeing none um if you are in
favor of the motion when your when your
name is called signify by saying I if
you're opposed nay
um and the clerk will call the role
thank you Mr chair representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
yes representative kazinski yes
representative
Bowden representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative con represent
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar I representative
Faulkner yes representative Newman yes
representative Eaton yes representative
Peterson yeses Peterson Peterson correct
yes representative Greg yes
representative jurus yes chairman mononi
I Mr chair the motion passes
180 thank
you and again I'm okay with consent I
mean unless any gu any objections to be
on the consent
calendar seeing none thank
you we will move to uh House Bill 456
relative to collecting road tolls on the
output of separately metered Electric
vehicle
Chargers recognize resent Mills for a
motion Mr chair I vote
itl motion is made to itl is there a
second to the motion
second
second who who seconded please
Eaton
discussion seeing none if you're uh if
you're in favor of the motion to itl
You'll signify by saying I on House Bill
456 FN if you're opposed nay when the
clerk is
ready thank you Mr chair representative
cluder yes representative Mills votes
yes representative fedolfi
represent representative kazinski yes
representative
Bowden representative boy o votes I
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton yes representative Peterson yes
representative Greg yes
representative jurus yes chairman maconi
I Mr chair the vote passes 18
Z thank
you um we will move to House Bill six do
we want to put that on on
consent is there any objection to
putting it on consent seeing
none thank
you
we'll move on to House Bill 606 FN
requiring construction of state
buildings or state funded projects to
contain electric vehicles EV charging
infrastructure I I recognize represent
Mills for a uh
motion Mr chair I move interim study on
HB 606
seconded uh motion motion made by Mill
seconded by
Boyd uh discussion
Mr chairman repres I'm going to vote in
favor of interterm study I think this is
a well-intentioned bill but it it it I
think it does need some work in the
sense it talks about state buildings and
state funded housing projects I'm not
aware of any housing projects and I also
believe there's another bill that
Transportation a study committee House
Bill 111 and I'm anxious I've have not
seen the a final report which should
have been filed on November 1 so I'd
like to take a look at that and with
this bill and maybe work something out
uh but I'm I think we should be careful
about duplicating possibly something
that Transportation or this study
committee on house bill 111 is working
but I think this is an important issue
and I commend the sponsors for doing
this but obviously this issue and this
bill and uh 606 does need some work uh
that we really need to do before we can
pass it thank you thank you further
discussion concur with the vice
Chairman's uh thoughts on this bill um
so with no further discussion motion's
been made has been seconded if you're in
favor of the motion for interim study uh
606 uh you'll signify by saying I if
you're opposed Nay with that the clerk
will call the role thank you Mr chair
representative cludia uh
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
yes representative kazinski yes
representative Bowden yes representative
Boyd Boyd votes
I representative Melvin yes
representative
bogert yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative fauler yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton yes representative Peterson yes
representative Greg yes representative
jurus yes chairman mcon I Mr chair the
motion passes
180 internum
study so on on the motion of inm study
it goes to the floor and the floor will
then decide am I right on that
M it's not like retain we will have to
bring this to the floor I don't know if
there'll be any debate but it is
possible it could be debated and needs
to be voted on by the full house but uh
unless there's any objection we could
put it I believe we can put it on
consent with an interm even with an
interm study we
can we're okay with that okay so without
objection we will put it on the consent
bring us brings us to our last piece of
uh work for
today um House Bill 110 prohibiting the
use of State funds for new railro uh new
passenger rail
projects I um just want to note that the
um committee had been sent a couple
correspondences that I know were passed
along uh the chair will recognize
represent Mills for a motion thank you
Mr chair at this point I move interim
study
seconded motion made by Bill seconded by
Boyd uh interim study House Bill
110 is there a
discussion uh Mr chairman I think this
is a very contentious and controversial
issue I realize we are still Gathering I
think data and I think gaset is is
consider I don't if they're going to put
it in but even if we did put it in term
study we're probably going to continue
with this ISS issue and it may be part
of the debate on the 10-year plan next
year so I just the bill itself I have
some some problems with uh so I'm I'm
commend but I know there are some
concerns that the uh sponsors of the
bill are concerned about so I suppose
it's better to listen to them and why
they object to passenger rail I'm by the
way on the opposite side but I'm trying
to keep an open mind so I think interm
study for now will delay the process
until we can maybe debate it further
next year maybe as part of the 10-year
plan thank you thank you is there
further
discussion okay seeing none uh the
motion has been made and seconded uh
House Bill 110 to go to inm study
prohibiting the use of State funds for
new passenger rail projects if you're in
favor of the motion uh to go to inm
study you signify by saying I and if
you're opposed the it will be nay with
that the clerk will call the role thank
you Mr chair representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fidi I representative
representative
kazinski representative
Bowden representative Boyd Boyd vot ey
representative Melvin hi representative
bogert
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar I representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton yes representative Peterson yes
representative Greg yes representative
jurus
yes chairman mcon uh chairman votes I Mr
chair the motion passes 180 for interm
study and uh would
U would anyone have issue with putting
it on
consent seeing none we'll start there
with it and um I want to I want to thank
the committee for coming in today I want
to thank those that are present and for
those that are present and to my
committee this is why I love this
committee thank you for your
time
motion to
adjourn all right favor of the motion
I any
opposed